our next guest is an oscar-winning
actress author businesswoman mom
storyteller
and overall game changer and i'm lucky
enough to call her
my friend we've actually known each
other since we are about
14.
um she is also the voice of rosita the
pig in the sing movie of the sequel sing
two which hit theaters today
please welcome the magnanimous
intelligent beautiful bright funny wise
cool
reese witherspoon
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
looking good by
i
the
way
to see you and this set is so gorgeous
well you know we are women who are
fun-loving but we don't mess around when
it comes to certain things
but
today we are celebrating nurses
and every member in this audience is a
nurse
and
yes
[Applause]
that you
were raised
by a mother
who is a nurse yeah that's right tell me
about your mom oh my gosh you're gonna
make me cry i i was talking to my mom on
the phone when your producer called and
said the whole audience was filled with
nurses and my mom and i both started to
cry
um because being raised by a nurse i
think
my mother has such infinite compassion
and when i there's my mom's first little
id card i think is memphis tennessee
and she got to be in the newspaper
because she was one of the youngest
nurses in in memphis
um but i'm just so
i remember being a teenager and going
and my mother worked night shifts she
worked weekends so i had to kind of take
care of myself my brother and i would
you know make dinner and everything she
was so tired but she just loved her
patients and she did labor and delivery
she did intensive care neonatal
intensive care and um i would bring her
donuts her and the other nurses but i
was just in awe of
her endless compassion for other people
and that's how i feel whenever i see a
nurse
because i think to dedicate your life to
caring for people is one of the most
noble professions that exists so thank
you for your incredible hard work taking
people during this very difficult
time know
the fact that
nurses are now the superheroes
and in the spotlight
um that every entertainer gets to be in
that they are the superstars and the
cape wearers
it should have never not been this way
but a silver lining that can come out of
this
difficult time this pandemic that i wish
we could have never had to experience
but since we did and we cannot change
history as we live in the present and go
into the future how can we make the
world a different place
we can put nurses on the pedestal that
they deserve to be on that's right so
[Applause]
i heard your mom had a good bedside
manner is that true yes
my mom was awesome
you know what's so funny she went to go
get her covered vaccine and
the the lady who was going to give her
her coach vaccine she said can i tell
you something because my mom also taught
nursing at the state university in
tennessee that's right she goes you were
my professor
her name was nancy and she had been my
mom's student so it's just about like i
always i always reckon with just what
you were talking about as an actor we
get so much attention but my mother and
father my dad was a doctor my mom was a
nurse i've watched my mother save
people's lives whether it was save a kid
from drowning she helped her very best
friend had a bad accident when we were
very little and i watched her
resuscitate her on the side of a highway
like there is so much um
we don't focus and highlight on the
people who do that hard difficult work
of saving lives um so i'm so glad that
you're doing this today to highlight and
also encourage more people to be nurses
it's such a
incredible profession and you know it's
always hard to get people to do it you
know and you think it's so rewarding and
i remember even though my mom was tired
she was like i have purpose
and having purpose in your life is such
a big part of being a human being like
what are we here for we're here to care
for each other you know and when you
have a sense of purpose yeah which i
know you must embody because you're
pulling so many levers
and with keeping ego out of it i know
you're aware of all the things you're
just too smart not to be you're a 360
thinker and um
it's going to be christmas we're three
days away from christmas
um i would love to know what ava deacon
and tennessee what do you guys have
planned any traditions you know we're
just doing the regular stuff we're going
to be with my mom and and hanging out
with um you know the whole family just
do it we like oh yeah we dress up you
know trying to get all the family
members in one picture is really my goal
for the year why is it so hard to get
the perfect screensaver if you have
children it is like it takes five years
to get it i mean really someone has a
weird face someone's not paying like
that's all i like it doesn't work all i
want for christmas is all my kids in one
photo smiling hopefully smiling
i feel like i want to call all of them
and be like okay this is what you saw
for christmas but now ava and deacon are
what they are modeling for beyonce
that's right
tell us everything
[Applause]
i mean they got called to be in
beyonce's new ivy park campaign and they
got to go and work together they had the
best time
[Applause]
beyonce was so sweet to them so nice
they got to be on set with her and her
kids and of course she's just you know
the loveliest most creative human too i
mean she's a powerhouse everything she
does she touches with her um her
artistry her creativity and her activism
and they were just blown away i mean the
thing is all they ever they had nearly
passed out they were so excited
[Music]
you